Guten Tag.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz-Servientin tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen heute das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, klar, logisch, ja.
So, als ich möchte ein paar personische Daten aufnehmen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Manfred Simon.
Manfred Simon, könnten Sie Ihren Nachname und Vorname Buchstabinen beenden?
Ja, der Nachname ist S-I-M-U-N Simon.
Und der Vorname ist Manfred M-A-N-F-R-E-D.
Ja, okay, Herr Simon.
Herr Simon, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin schon 74.
Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 25. April, 48.
Okay. Herr Simon, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin, ja, ich glaube immer noch 1,78.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ja, ich bin noch 89 kg.
Okay Herr Simon, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also mir geht es seit einer ganzen Weide nicht gut.
Und jetzt habe ich immer so Luftnot, wenn ich die Treppe hochlaufe.
Da kriege ich mit einmal gar keine Luft mehr.
Und habe auch das Gefühl, mein Herz schlägt ganz schnell.
Und dann muss ich also stehen bleiben und Pause machen.
Am liebsten würde ich mir eine Stuhl auf den Treppenabsetz stellen.
Und ein bisschen Husten habe ich schon immer.
Aber das ist jetzt ein bisschen schlimmer geworden.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Hüste?
Also eigentlich huste ich schon seit 4 Jahren.
Aber ich habe ja auch früher viel geraucht.
Und gut in meinem Alter, da hustete man halt mal.
Aber jetzt kommt da mit einmal so blutiges Zeug raus.
Und ja, das fühlt sich jetzt nicht so gut an.
Und seit wann sind diese Hüste schlimmer geworden?
Ja, vielleicht so im letzten Vierteljahr.
Okay, in den letzten vierte Jahr.
Und Sie haben einmal Blut im Auswurf?
Ja, das ist schon häufiger.
Häufiger, okay.
Sind diese Blut rot oder braun?
Ja, das sieht so komisch-rötlich aus.
Rötlich, wie ein Linie, wie streichen, glaube ich.
Ja, irgendwie so, ja.
Okay, Herr Simon, seit wann haben Sie diese Atemnot beschwerden?
Ja, das ist jetzt in den letzten Wochen schlimmer geworden.
Ja, also, dass ich nicht mehr so gut die Treppe hochgekommen bin.
Das war jetzt schon längere Zeit.
Aber dass ich so das Gefühl habe, ich kriege überhaupt gar keine Luft mehr.
Und das mit des Herzes einklopft.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich erst seit Kurzem.
Und deswegen habe ich auch gedacht, ich muss jetzt mal hierher kommen.
Okay, Sie haben das Richtige gemacht.
Okay, ich möchte fragen, gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für Ihre Atemnot,
die aus der Treppe hochgehen?
Können Sie gut laufen oder gut schlafen?
Ja, also beim Schlafen, da habe ich schon so meine Nöte,
die Nacht einzuschlafen.
Und zwischen du, ich muss sie natürlich auch mal rausgehen,
um auf die Toilette zu gehen.
Aber dann muss ich nach, natürlich schon auch husten,
das ist schon richtig da.
Und mit wie viel Kissen schlafen Sie?
Ja, also zwei habe ich da schon, ja, zwei Dicke.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schlafstörende?
Auch seit langem?
Schon lange.
Das habe ich schon lange, ja.
Und haben Sie Schwedengön an Ihren Beinen bemerkt?
Schwedengön, war nicht das, bin ich aufgefallen.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Herzrasten haben?
Ja, das ist, wenn ich die Treppe hochgehen und wenn ich so schrecklich husten muss,
dann denke ich immer, das kommt alles zusammen.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber glaube ich nicht, ich habe das jetzt nicht gemessen,
aber glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Aber ich fühle mich so ein bisschen schlapp, das stimmt schon, ne?
Sie fühlen sich schlapp, seit wann?
Seid ich schon lange auch?
Ja, jetzt seit ein paar Monaten, der versucht, ja, nicht schon die ganzen Jahre,
aber so in den letzten Monaten, ja, fühle ich mich schon schlechter.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie früher viel geraucht haben.
Rauchten Sie noch, immer noch?
Ja, ich rauch hin und wieder so ein, zwei Pfeifen am Tag rauche ich noch.
Ein, zwei, fünf.
Ja, früher habe ich aber ordentlich Zigaretten geraucht, ne?
Wie viel?
Aber da konnte ich natürlich nicht so schnell davon abkommen.
Okay, wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie damals geraucht?
Ja, ich habe 40 Jahre.
Wow, meine ganze Berufstätigkeit habe ich eigentlich immer geraucht.
Ich habe bestimmt 40 Jahre, habe ich so am Tag 1,5 Päckchen geraucht.
Und jetzt rauchen Sie ein, zwei, fünf, seit wann?
Ja, seit 10 Jahren ungefähr.
Am ganz kann ich es doch nicht lassen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen in Ihrem Brustkorb oder etwas anderes?
Ja, beim Wusten tut es halt so weh, ne?
Wo genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe so das Gefühl, wenn ich huste, dass mir das dann schon so, so, so im Brustkorb so weh tut.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
1 bedeutet sehr leicht.
Kann wir aushalten, also vielleicht so 5 oder so, oder 4?
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und schätzt dann diese Schmerzen irgendein wohin aus?
Ne, eigentlich nicht.
Gibt es andere Auslöser, Äußererhüsten für diese Schmerzen?
Oder gibt es bestimmte, dünnende Faktoren?
Es ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, also ich merke das ja nicht die ganze Zeit, es tut nicht die ganze Zeit weh.
Okay.
Und haben Sie das bemerkt, dass Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen oder zugenommen haben?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich abgenommen, ich schmeckt so gar nicht, ne?
Ich habe so gar keinen Appetit und da heißt ich natürlich auch alleine und ich mag mal nicht kochen und nicht essen.
Und ich habe 6 kg abgenommen im letzten halben Jahr.
6 kg in den letzten 6 Monaten.
Und Sie haben weniger Appetit.
Ich habe ja keinen Appetit.
Haben Sie das bemerkt, dass Ihr Bauch größer geworden?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Haben Sie Darmbeschwerden?
Nein.
Okay.
Okay, Ihre aktuelle Beschwörden habe ich alles notiert, glaube ich.
Ich möchte fragen, ob Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen haben?
Ja, also auch der Prostator habe ich, ne?
Das ist schon seit 10 Jahren, deswegen muss ich nachts auch oft mal auf die Toilette.
Dann nehme ich auch irgendwelche Tabletten, aber ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie die heißen.
Haben Sie die Medikamentanliste dabei?
Nein, die Liste habe ich jetzt nicht mitnehmen.
Wie viel mal nehmen Sie diese Tablette für Prostator?
Die nehme ich einmal am Tag.
Und Prostator?
Bitte?
Prostator haben Sie etwas anderes.
Ja, der Brutdruck ist auch ein bisschen hoch.
Dann nehme ich so Tabletten, die heißen Konkur, dann nehme ich eine am Morgen.
Wie heißen die Tabletten? Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Konkur heißen die Tabletten, Konkur 50.
Konkur 50.
Okay.
Einmal pro Tag?
Ja.
Und dann habe ich, im linken Auge habe ich auch Probleme, da habe ich grauen Stader,
muss ich regelmäßig Augen tropfen nehmen.
Haben Sie schon mal deswegen operiert worden?
Nein, ich will mich nicht operieren lassen, weil gar nichts mehr.
Aber ich bin natürlich schon operiert worden.
Ja, als Kind habe ich am Winter auch rausbekommen.
Und dann hatte ich vor zehn Jahren mal eine Bandscheibenoperation.
Und jetzt hatte ich wieder ein Bandscheibenvorfall vor drei Jahren,
aber ich will es nicht noch mal operieren lassen.
Das ist so unangenehm und ich bin da schon so alt,
da will ich nichts mehr machen lassen.
Okay, verstehe.
Sie wurden zweimal operiert.
Okay.
Nein, ich hatte noch längerer Zeit, ja schon 20 Jahre her,
da ist mal die geilen Blase entfernt worden.
Okay, 40 Jahre, Kalamien-Entfernung.
Mhm.
Sind diese Operationen Komplikationen ausverfahren?
Ja, da war eigentlich nichts Besonderes.
Mhm.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe zwei Sachen, wo ich aufpassen muss.
Das eine ist Nauvalgin.
Das darf ich nicht nehmen.
Und ich habe auch eine Iodallägie.
Was passiert, wenn Sie mit Nauvalgin begegnen?
Ja, wenn ich das einnehme, dann kriege ich halt mit einer schlechten Luft
und ich kriege auch so einen Hautjucken.
Okay.
Und mit Iod, was ist passiert mit Iod?
Ja, da kriege ich auch so einen Ausschlag auf der Haut.
Nur Ausschlag, keine Luftnot.
Mhm.
Okay.
Herr Simon, gibt es irgendetwas wichtiges Gerrkrankungen
in Ihrem Familie?
Bei Ihrem Vater oder bei Ihrer Mutter?
Ja, mein Vater, der hatte halt ein Herz in Schafz.
Er ist 74 Jahre alt geworden, also so alt wie ich jetzt bin.
Und meine Mutter, die ist mit 72, hat großkrebs gestorben.
Es tut mir leid.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Wohnen Sie allein, Herr Simon?
Ja, ja, ich wohne alleine, meine Frau ist gestorben
und meine Töchter gehen alle ihre eigenen Wege.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, drei Töchter habe ich.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die sind alle gesund, ja, so viel ich weiß, ja.
Und Herr Simon, trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, also Alkohol würde ich jetzt nicht sagen,
aber so abends ein Flaschen Bier, das trinke ich wohl, ja.
Abends ein Flaschen Bier?
Eine Flasche Bier, ja.
Mhm.
Und mit Drogen haben Sie nichts zu tun, nehme ich mal an.
Nein, nein, nein, also dafür bin ich zu alt.
Ja.
Okay, ich möchte noch etwas über Ihre aktuelle Bescheidung fragen.
Haben Sie Schluckbescheidung?
Schluck, das ist mir eigentlich nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Mhm.
Oder Heiserkeit?
Ja, manchmal bin ich morgen so ein bisschen heiser,
aber das geht dann im Laufe des Tages weg.
Okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche an in Ihrem Körper Liftknoten bemerkt?
Nymphknoten, keine Ahnung, nee.
Haben Sie nicht bemerkt?
Weiß ich nichts von.
Okay, Herr Simon, ich glaube, dass wir alles gesprochen haben,
möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich wüsste nur ganz gerne, was ich von gegen den Husten machen kann
und ja, dass es mir wieder ein bisschen besser geht.
Aber ich sage gleich, ob wir rühren lassen, will ich mich nicht.
Ja, Sie brauchen nicht operiert werden.
Ja.
Zuerst möchte ich Ihre ein paar Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Wenn alles stabil ist, dann möchte ich ein paar körperische Untersuchungen
und ein paar Laboruntersuchungen durchführen.
Okay.
Wenn wir die Ergebnisse bekommen, wir können widerspringen.
Das klingt vernünftig, ja.
Okay, dann warte ich.
Okay, dann warten Sie hier, ich komme wieder.
Sehr gut.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Erstens, ich spreche meine Denken.
Ich finde, es ist eine hervorragende Bechüpfung.
Würde ich auch so sagen, ja.
Sehr gut.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ich brauche ein paar Minuten für alles gut, ja.
Was denken Sie, Frau Gerhild, diese annämmnende Bechüpfung?
Super.
Sie ist sehr dringend.
Fieber hat sie gefragt?
Ja.
Frau Erzl hat alles gefragt.
Sehr schön.
Ja, wirklich.
Das war echt super.
Auch sprachlich, wirklich ausgesprochen gut.
Sehr gut.
Ich denke, das ist, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, ein Mainzerfall.
Nein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Bitte?
Diese Simulation vorher zwei oder dreimal gehabt.
Ja, ja, aber sie kommen aus Mainz, der Fall kommt aus Mainz.
Ja.
Ja, ich habe die richtig, zweimal schon gemacht, ja.
Sie haben ein Gedächtnis, das ist unglaublich, ja.
Kannst du dir anfangen, Arsatzge-Sypria?
Ja, ja, einen Moment.
Auf dieser analysischen Angabe gehe ich an Herzinsuffizienz aus.
Ja, einen Moment. Ich muss mit Oberarzt spielen.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Ja, klar.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie es seit hätten, würde ich Ihnen gerne vorstellen.
Gut.
Herr Simon ist 74 Jahre altiger Patient.
Er hat sich bei uns schon lange gedauern,
mit Luftnot, Dispne, Taschikade und Husten vorgestellt.
Diese Beschwerden sind schon lange bei ihm,
aber in der letzten Zeit sind diese Beschwerden schlimmer geworden.
Er hat häufig Hemoptese gehabt.
Er hat Schwierigkeiten, besonders beim Treppen hochgehen.
Er hat Dispne und Angina Pectoris, manchmal R-R-R.
Er hat Fatigue seit ein paar Monaten.
Er kann nicht wegen der Nocturie und Husten gut schlafen.
Er muss mit zwei Kisten schlafen.
Trotzdem hat er schlechte Schlafkoholität.
Er hat seit sechs Monaten Abgenomen über Appetitlosigkeit.
Er hat über Prostatahiparapylosik erzählt.
Seit zehn Jahren leidet er Prostatahiparapylosik.
Er nimmt eine Tablete ein,
aber er erinnert die Namen des Tabletes nicht.
Er hat eine Arterelle-Hypertonie,
seit langem.
Er nimmt eine Konkurve, 50 Milligramm, einmal Prostatat.
Er hat Kataract,
deswegen benutzt er Augentropfen.
Er wurde dreimal operiert.
Als Kind wurde er wegen Appendix operiert.
Vor zehn Jahren wurde er wegen Bandscheibenvorfall operiert.
Vor 20 Jahren wurde er wegen Kohlestitis operiert.
Seit drei Jahren leidet er auch wieder an Bandscheibenvorfall.
Er will nicht wieder operiert werden.
Er ist gegen Novalgin und J-Allergisch.
Die Novalgin-Allergie äußert sich mit Anaphylaktikreaktionen.
Mit J äußert diese Allergie exantem aus.
Bei der Familiengeschichte gibt es bei dem Vater Herzinfarkt.
Bei der Mutter gibt es Brustkrebs.
Beide sind gestorben.
Er hat keine Geschwester.
Herr Simon raucht seit mehr als 40 Jahren.
Früher hat er viel geraut, 1,5 Päckchen pro Tag.
Seit zehn Jahren raucht er 102 Pfeifen.
Er trinkt jeden Abend eine Flasche Bia.
Er hat keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Nein.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Als Verdachtdiagnose denke ich über Herzinsuffizienz.
Was wäre differentialdiagnostisch noch möglich?
Als differentialdiagnostisch käme Lungenembolie oder Tuberkulose in Betracht.
Tuberkulose?
Ah ja, okay.
Haben Sie noch eine weitere Alternative?
Ja, Bronchialcardinom.
Die sind meine differentialdiagnostische Themen.
Was würden Sie jetzt diagnostisch mit den Patienten anstellen?
Ich habe zuerst die Vitalparameter überprüft.
Alles war stabil.
Ich möchte jetzt körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie besonders?
Ja, ich muss erst die Inspektion machen.
Zum Beispiel Schwellung an Beine oder Blödsinn.
Blödsinn, kann ich sehen.
Ich kann die Dispne auch sehen, wenn der Patient jetzt hat.
Ich werde das Herz abhören, auch die Lungen abhören.
Ich werde das auch abtasten, ob es eine Vergrößerung von Leber oder Milz hat.
Genau.
Was machen Sie weiter?
Ich werde Blutuntersuchungen durchführen.
Was untersuchen Sie da im Alkohol?
Blutbild, CRP, Blutzenkungsgeschwindigkeit und BNP für Herzinsubizidienz.
Was würden Sie noch labortechnisch untersuchen?
Leber-Testung und Nieren-Testung.
Ich meine jetzt unabhängig von Blutuntersuchungen.
Ich würde gerne Aufnahme durchführen.
Ich bin noch im Labor.
Auswurfuntersuchungen.
Ja, genau. Die Zytologie.
Ja, Zytologie.
Ob es ein Bronchial-Kartz noch gibt oder nicht.
Genau.
Gut. Was machen wir dann?
Abgerätiv weiter.
Ja, ich würde aufnahme durchführen.
Ich kann sehen, ob es Vergrößerung von Herz gibt.
Ich kann die Situation von Lungen sehen.
Ich kann eine Echokardiographie durchführen.
Ich kann die Funktion von dem Herz richtig sehen.
Mit EKG kann ich sehen, ob es eine Vergrößerung in Herz gibt.
Wenn sich das Herz gar nicht als das Problem rausstellt,
wenn das Herz eher unauffällig ist?
Ja, ich kann mich auf Lungen konzentrieren.
Ob es eine Pleural-Argus gibt, kann ich sehen.
Was kann man dann noch für eine weitere komplexe Diagnostik machen?
Weitere komplexe Diagnostik.
Ich kann auch Kompetentomographie durchführen.
Ja, genau.
Ja, Bronchoscopy kann ich auch durchführen.
Mit Gewebeprobe.
Ja, mit Gewebeprobe.
Ja, und dann wissen wir ganz genau, ob da was sitzt oder nicht.
Genau.
Okay, Entschuldigung.
Dieser Patient hat Schnupfen.
Gut verletzt, warum?
Ja, tatsächlich war es das Bronchalkazinum.
Wobei ich vielleicht nicht gut genug gespielt habe,
weil ich nicht genug gehustet habe.
Das Problem kann von mir auch sein.
Ja, sie haben sich ein bisschen auf die Luft not beim Treppensteigen.
Sie sind ein bisschen eingefahren.
Aber gerade dieser blutige Ausmesser,
und eigentlich auch die Raucheranalyse, die ja schon ein bisschen krass ist,
spricht natürlich schon dafür.
Und natürlich auch, dass der Patient so ein bisschen
ja, desinteressiert ist,
eigentlich an seinem Gesundheitszustand.
Der achtet ja nicht so besonders gut auf sich.
Die Nukturie hat ja auch einen großen
Ja, das hat nichts damit zu tun.
Aber genau.
Also der Gewichtsverlust spricht natürlich schon für eine Karzinomgeschichte.
Und klar, was würde man dann jetzt, wenn sich das bestätigt,
würde man natürlich noch was machen?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen.
Aber das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen.
Man muss zuerst die Stufen, die Karzinom einstufen.
Ja, und was würde man sicherlich noch machen,
wenn man weiß, dass da was ist,
wenn das Logenkartzinom positiv ist,
wonach würde man Sicherheitshalber noch gucken?
Ob es irgendwo andere Krebs, GWB geht.
Ja, wie nennen wir das?
Metastas.
Ja, genau.
Also würde man nochmal MRT oder CT machen
zur Metastasensuche, ganz genau.
Ja, also Sie könnten morgen Ihre Prüfung machen.
Ja, aber ich muss zuerst die Verdacht, dass es ja gut ist.
Ja, aber es geht ja nicht um eine Fachprüfung,
es geht um die Sprache.
Und Sie haben sowohl die Anamese wirklich sprachlich,
sehr schön gemacht als auch den Bericht.
Ich wüsste nicht, was man daran verbessern könnte.
Sie sind wirklich super gewesen.
Und ich habe mich als Patient auch sehr gut aufgehoben,
gefühlt und Sie haben auch sehr vollständig den Oberarzt
über den Patienten informiert.
Ja, da, wie lange lern Sie schon Deutsch?
Entschuldigung?
Wo?
Wie lange sprechen Sie schon Deutsch?
Seit drei Jahren.
Ja, super.
Sie sind wirklich, sprachlich sehr sicher unterwegs.
Und dann haben Sie keine Sorge.
Hoffentlich, vielen Dank für Ihre Hilfe.